[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 nous sommes le
mercredi 13 juin tout de suite les
titres de cette édition
ils dénoncent notamment une dégradation
de leurs conditions de travail les
facteurs des yvelines débrayeront demain
la distribution du courrier risque donc
d'être très perturbé un appel à la grève
illimitée lancé par la cgt vincent
fournier de la cgt fo a pété 78 est avec
nous pour en parler
[Musique]
ce mouvement lui a pris fin à la
mi-journée les agriculteurs ont levé
leur blocage à la raffinerie de
coignières depuis lundi ils étaient
mobilisés contre l'importation de
produits agricoles elle ne respectant
pas les normes françaises et européennes
bilan en plateau avec alexandre ruesch
adhérents des jeunes agriculteurs
d'ile-de-france et ils sont les grands
vainqueurs les collégiens de la mare au
sol à coignières ont gagné le sic mitre
2018 c'est le championnat inter collèges
de match d'improvisation théâtrale est
les phases finales se tenait tir soir à
la merise attrape retour
deux invités autour de la table avec moi
donc en plateau vincent fournier bonsoir
soins vous êtes le représentant
départemental de la cgt fo péter des
yvelines vous appeler demain jeudi à une
grève illimitée des facteurs dans le
département restez avec nous on va en
parler dans un instant je me tourne
d'abord vers vous alexander resch
bonsoir soit vous êtes adhérent des
jeunes agriculteurs d'ile-de-france
exploitants à bailly vous étiez
mobilisés depuis lundi devant le dépôt
de carburant de coignières un blocage
qui a été levée depuis la fin de matinée
c'est une mobilisation qui une feinte de
mobilisation qui s'est faite dans le
calme
vous étiez une soixantaine cinq sections
de crs soit 150 hommes étaient également
sur place pas de pas de tensions avec
les forces de l'ordre lors de votre
départ
alors il ya eu des tensions au moment
des pourparlers pour la fin de lever de
levage du blocage
après tout s'est déroulée convenablement
de ce qu'on a respecté nos engagements
et eux aussi
donc on a pu plier bagages et rentrer
sur nos fermes dans ce blocage il y
avait des agriculteurs de la fdsea des
jeunes agriculteurs d'île de france et
également du loiret qui participait donc
à ce mouvement depuis lundi quel climat
régner dans vos troupes
sur ces trois jours un climat assez
apaisés sur l'aspect message passé et
lutte sur lequel on s'était mobilisée
malgré tout
on en ressort déçu abattu trois jours de
mobilisation
c'est pas grand chose mais il faut tenir
ces trois jours et être présent et
relayer 24 heures sur 24 sur voilà avec
différents départements qui sont venus
nous réveiller
il faut savoir qu'il y avait quand même
quatre points en ile-de-france sur toute
la région dans le 95 à gennevilliers
dans le 77 à grandpuits et aussi à
grigny dans le 91
nous avons
était très déçu à la suite des annonces
de notre syndicat et du ministère de
l'agriculture
suite à leurs échanges qu'ils ont eus la
nuit passée alors il disait hier
justement vos représentants que le
compte n'y était pas pourquoi finalement
mettre fin au blocage aujourd'hui après
cette rencontre avec l'honneur ces
agricultures oui tout à fait pourquoi
parce que la pression était forte de la
part des gendarmes et des crs et de la
préfecture
il y avait eu un message très clair
passer par le gouvernement et ensuite
c'était un appel à mobilisation de notre
syndicat national donc nous nous sommes
arrangés derrière cette annonce de don
et et les barrages
on rappelle que votre mobilisation
s'adressait directement gouvernement
vous dénonciez la concurrence déloyale
de l'huile de palme face aux productions
nationales de colza et de tournesol le
groupe total a été autorisé par le
gouvernement a utilisé cette huile de
palme pour cette bioraffinerie dans la
merde et ce qu'il y a tout de même
alexandre umesh des points d'avancé des
garanties qui ont été prises par le
gouvernement
est-ce qu'il ya quand même des points
positifs à la fin de cette cette
mobilisation alors sur le sujet huile de
palme le point si je peux dire positif
c'est le fait de vouloir porter aux
magnans au niveau européen un
abaissement de l'introduction de l'huile
de palme dans les biocarburants
ce qu'il faut comprendre sur la
problématique huile de palme est en
opposition à l'huile de colza l'huile de
colza est une filière qui s'est
structuré depuis de longues années pour
notre agriculture et qui a un vrai à un
vrai atout pour notre agriculture
car ça nous permet d'avoir une autonomie
alimentaire pour les protéines animales
pour nourrir notre bétail et donc c'est
un cercle très vertueux parce que nous
arrivons à nourrir notre aliments notre
bétail grâce aux tourteaux donc au des
produits aux sous-produits après
extraction de l'huile d'accord ce qui
permet de
importé moins de produits moins de
protéines niveau mondial donc
pas de protéines avec des ogm bon nombre
d'agriculteurs sont rentrés dans les
filières organisées
labellisé san jose ogm si on met à mal
cette organisation de filière qui
aujourd'hui fonctionne très bien et
apporte sur toutes les productions à un
bénéfice on va avoir des labels qui vont
s'écrouler avoir des difficultés à
s'auto consommer des produits français
pour l'alimentation des animaux
c'est à dire vous attendiez des
commandes ird et des points d'avancé sur
sur le sujet vous n'en avez pas assez eu
il ya des déceptions forcément vous le
disais tout à l'heure vous êtes
relativement déçu il y a de la déception
et d'incompréhension dans la politique
de ce gouvernement
quand on ressort des états généraux de
l'alimentation qui nous sont d'ailleurs
pas totalement abouti ou en un temps
bien les attentes de la société civile
sur la qualité alimentaire la qualité
environnementale
on ne comprend pas cette position là
c'est une filière bénéfique pour notre
agriculture pour notre pays
ça va totalement à l'encontre de ce
qu'il en ressort dans les états généraux
de favoriser et de créer des filières là
on est en train d'en potentiellement
d'en démonter une donc incompréhension
totale da par nos agriculteurs ce qu'on
comprend pas non plus et vu l'impact
qu'à l'huile de palme au niveau bilan
carbone écologique on le connaît tous
comment fonctionnent-ils de palme et
comment ces produits on n'a pas entendu
sur ce sujet manière fort nicolas hulot
il est aux abonnés absents on est
rarement déçu écologique y est
il ne s'est pas exprimée en tout cas
publiquement sur le sujet sinon et donc
on se pose la question
ce que le gouvernement prime et quel est
intérêt il va y porte pour notre
agriculture j'ai là on a vraiment le
sentiment qu'ils portent un intérêt pour
ces grosses entreprises pour de
l'importation de produits qui n'ont pas
les mêmes cahiers des charges les mêmes
normes que nous nous avons dans notre
agriculture française et c'est vrai que
on est totalement perdu et désavoué de
cette position du gouvernement
donc on nous attendent par rapport aux
syndics son engagement qu'a donnée le
ministre de l'agriculture suite aux
rencontres avec la profession comme un
empilement si il y à un engagement de
réorganiser la les importations
distorsives dit storti vrie pour l'après
est donc une prise en compte des règles
et des normes
j'ai encore beaucoup de mal à y croire
merci alexandre rêve d'avoir été avec
moi je rappelle que vous êtes adhérent
des jeunes agriculteurs d'ile-de-france
a également exploitant à bailly après
une journée de grosses perturbations
hier la décrue s'amorce dans les
yvelines plusieurs communes touchées par
les inondations ont d'ores et déjà
demandé la reconnaissance d'état de
catastrophe naturelle comme saint rémy
les chevreuse ou les équipes municipales
sont à pied d'oeuvre pour nettoyer la
ville avec l'aide des agents de magny
les hameaux
l autoroute a13 à elle rouvert dans les
deux sens de circulation dans la soirée
d'hier
pour rappel plus de 1000 interventions
des pompiers ont eu lieu dans les
yvelines
l'actualité du jour c'est également la
visite du ministre de l'intérieur gérard
collomb a manqué mantes la jolie
le ministre de l'intérieur se rendra ce
soir à 20 heures au commissariat de la
ville là où son loi ou officiers pardon
et jessica schnyder secrétaire
administrative et et jean baptiste
salvin major de police ce couple tué à
son domicile dans l'attentât de
magnanville le 13 juin 2016 par un homme
qui se réclamait de l'état islamique
le ministre était déjà venu l'an passé à
la même date et avait notamment inauguré
une plaque commémorative la distribution
du courrier risque d'être perturbée
demain jeudi dans les yvelines à l'appel
de la cgt les facteurs seront en grève
illimitée
vincent fournier je me tourne vers vous
vous êtes avec nous en plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes le représentant
départemental de la cgt fo a pété 78
alors une manifestation est prévue
demain dans les rues de saint quentin en
yvelines avant un rassemblement de votre
devant votre direction départementale
c'est à guyancourt
vous dénoncez dansant fournier une
dégradation de votre condition de
travail et également des réorganisations
incessantes du groupe depuis dix ans
concrètement quelles évolutions de votre
métier vous vous dénoncez par ce moment
alors une petite précision il ya eu des
petits changements depuis en fait ca
mantes la jolie qu'on votera sans blague
lorsque ont appris qu'ils avaient le
préfet sur place
donc toute la matinée sera avantageux à
dire et sinon les donc ce qu'on dénonce
en fait l'essentiel lasser les
réorganisations les suppressions
d'emplois il faut savoir que la poste a
supprimé environ 120 milles emplois au
moins ces quinze dernières années donc
c'est c'est énorme c'est un plan social
phénoménal et là l'essentiel en fait la
grosse attaque contre le métier de
facteur c'est la pause méridienne ce
qu'ils appellent la pause méridienne
en fait aujourd'hui le facteur
classiquement ils sont de ces horaires
c'est cette heure 13h30 et la peau cela
veut imposer de aux facteurs de
travailler toute la journée la journée
avec une pause la veille une pause le
midi et une préparation aussi de sa
tournée à 120 actuellement le facteur
préparer la tournée c'est après
quelqu'un en gros c'est trois heures de
préparation 3 heures 2 heures distribués
et là la poste veut imposer dans une
large majorité en tous cas dans les
yvelines deux sites de
faire en gros 9h 17h avec uniquement de
la distribution et on sait que c'est la
partie la plus la plus dure la plus
physique du métier et la tâche de tri et
de distribution va être totalement
séparés c'est ça les 6e la poste prévoit
de créer des sites de préparation dédié
aux tournées des îlots également de
proximité qui seront dédiés seulement à
la distribution vous ne pourrez plus
assurée donc dans ces conditions un
votre travail de façon convenable mais
déjà comme je commençais à le dire c'est
que ça va être beaucoup plus dur
physiquement parce que on imagine faire
9h 17h quand il pleut toute la journée
quand il fait 35 degrés l'été ça va
forcément être beaucoup plus dur est de
toute façon c'est beaucoup plus dur
puisque c'est soit en vélo soit en
voiture descente de voiture sans cesse
et c est du coup
ça va aussi impacté sur le service aux
usagers de la poste puisque ça va être
une distribution l'après-midi dans plein
de plein d'endroits ça va être à voir
son courrier des quotidiens on reçoit
des quotidiens des journaux on va les
avoir l'après midi à 16h à 17h fins et
c'est aussi un gros problème pour les
usagers alors ce à quoi la direction de
la poste répond vincent fournier des
organisations sont nécessaires avec un
volume de courrier en baisse un volume
de colis qui lui est en hausse dans le
département des attentes aussi qui
évolue une livraison des livraisons qui
doivent être dans des délais de plus en
plus courts et la poste dit que les
facteurs face à ces évolutions à ces
évolutions doivent adapter s'adapter oui
mais nous on considère pas ça du tout de
la même manière puisque la poste encore
fait un quasiment un milliard de
bénéfices en 2010 est le bénéfice
augmente tous les ans
les colis sont en augmentation
exceptionnelle c'est la cour mettant en
flèche sans cesse depuis des années il
ya d'autres activités le courrier c'est
discutable la baisse du trafic courrier
est aussi discutable en sachant qu'en
plus les plis sont de plus en plus gros
il ya tout un tas de même pour les
facteurs classiques y distribuer des
lettres on a des paquets maintenant un
port etc qui viennent de l'étranger de
plus en plus et les facteurs travaillent
plus aujourd'hui que il ya cinq ans ou
dix ans cette réorganisation est déjà en
place dans quelques communes du
département notamment et d'hambourg sur
le bassin de saint quentin
quelle remontée vous avez pu avoir sur
sur ses émissions des remontées qu'on a
c'est que c'est beaucoup plus dur la
préparation des fois est mal faite parce
qu'elle ait fait malheureusement par des
intérimaires qu'on a mal formés donc
c'est beaucoup plus difficile sur le
terrain aussi le facteur il n'a pas vu
ce qu'il avait ce qu'il a distribuées
donc c'est beaucoup plus dur
il est amené des fois on a eu des
témoignages terribles c'est que le
facteur doit re recouper le courrier sur
le trottoir carrément trier sa tournée
sur le trottoir parce que sinon il peut
pas distribuer correctement la direction
départementale indiqué chez nos
confrères des nouvelles la semaine
dernière qu'elle tenterait de vous
rencontrer avant ce mouvement est ce qu
à ce jour vous avez rencontré votre
église a rencontré lundi mais
aujourd'hui on n'y a pas d'avancées
réelles
en gros il préfère attendre que les
facteurs soient en grève et qu'il y ait
un impact sur la distribution plutôt que
de tenter de négocier sérieusement avant
dernière question chez vos collègues à
rennes il ya eu également une grève 130
jours de grève à la poste 25 jours en
gironde est ce que ce ce mouvement qui
va débuter demain dans les yvelines
pourrait s'étaler aussi sur sur la durée
il pourrait s'étaler sur la durée en
effet mais toutes façons d'en décider
demain c'est des facteurs qui vont
décider eux mêmes en assemblée générale
et si on est nombreux en effet
il est tout à fait possible que la grève
soit reconduite vendredi 150 grévistes
lors du dernier mouvement 132 sont votre
direction il faut mobiliser encore plus
demain on mobilise de encore depuis des
semaines depuis la dernière grève et on
a deux plutôt de bons échos et on pense
qu'il y aura encore plus de grévistes
demain merci vincent fournier d'avoir
été avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes
représentant départemental de la cgt fo
a pété des yvelines les facteurs qui
appelle donc demain à une grève
illimitée
la merise attrape avec lui hier soir les
phases finales du cycle mythe le dix
neuvième cycle mythe c'est le
championnat inter collèges de match
d'improvisation théâtrale sur scène à
quatre collèges saint quentinois qui se
sont entraînés tout au long de l'année
c'est le public qui était chargé de les
départager retour sur la soirée avec
aurélie rose
yves hub stand berger et patrick jacques
de dixmude
[Musique]
les connaissions déjà
non
explosion de joie pour nathan marie
cyrine nicolas arthur et la lie ce sont
ces collégiens de coignières qui ont été
désignés par le public de la merise pour
remporter le trophée de cette 19ème
édition du cycle est organisé par déclic
théâtre une année de travail récompensé
n'arrive pas à croire première année on
gagne la première fois du coup bah c'est
super et je sais pas comment expliquer l
enthousiasme
c'est génial gang des femmes à barbe ou
encore un navire sans avenir
durant la soirée 4 collège de trappes et
long cours montigny le bretonneux et
coignières se sont affrontés sur ces
thèmes d'improvisation pour ces phases
finales quelques règles à respecter
comme la construction de l'histoire et
le respect de la langue française à la
fin de chaque passage le public donne
son verdict pour sa première
participation le collège la mare au sol
a remporté tous les suffrages
ils viennent là avec juste la folie du
jeu est en fait du coup ils sont
complètement détachée de l'enjeu et
c'est ça qui a fait la différence
[Musique]
on a une grosse énergie vient
véritablement dans les collèges et ça
c'est vraiment très intéressant et au
delà de cette énergie de la créativité
de l'imaginaire cette année le
championnat inter collèges
d'improvisation théâtrale a réuni 15
établissements de saint quentin en
yvelines une participation record qui
pourrait bien augmenter pour la
prochaine édition
et cette soirée sera à revivre en
intégralité sur tv soixante dix huit
diffusion de ces phases finales du ciq
mythe les samedis 23 et 30 juin c'est à
chaque fois à 20h30
l action a été réalisée dans 60 villes à
travers la france hier mardi près de
trente personnes se sont rassemblées
devant la préfecture des yvelines à
versailles
une opération menée par l'antenne
départementale de l'association alliance
vita elle s'oppose à la gpa la gestation
pour autrui mais aussi aux évolutions
envisagées de la pma à la procréation
médicalement assistée pourrait être
ouverte prochainement aux femmes seules
ou en couple lesbien
c'était une promesse de campagne
d'emmanuel macron alliance vite accra
que le bébé le corps féminin ne
deviennent que de simples marchandises
écoutez les explications sur la
scénographie de l'action au micro de
michael ni d'euros on a un enfant qui
est tout seul sera c'est un tabouret il
est un sécurisé il était entouré de ses
parents et les personnes qui sont par
terre représentent les hommes et les
femmes qui deviennent juste des
pourvoyeurs de gamètes et dont la
paternité et la maternité ont été niés
et tu es donc en fait on tue le père on
est on tue la mer pour faire un petit
peu des enfants hors sol juste produits
avec des gamètes et une deuxième action
s'est également tenue en simultané dans
le département à saint germain en laye
une performance sportive pour la bonne
cause à présent le nageur franco-cubain
andy cabreira aviles a établi un nouveau
record 364 longueur en apnée à la
piscine aqua mundo de saint-cyr-l'ecole
l'eau était rempli de détritus afin de
sensibiliser lé spectateur à la
pollution des océans nicolas landry et
mickaël millero des ballons des
bouteilles des sacs en plastique c'est
dans cette décharge fictive que le
franco cubain andy cabreira villa
voulait tenter son nouveau record
d'apnée ce dimanche 10 juin objectif
dénoncer la pollution des océans se
glissant dans la peau d'un mammifère
marin et à plus de 3,5 millions de
tonnes des déchets les plastiques
d'invention donc c'est un mélange au
sein de déchets par minute ça à dire
tous ces saintes déchets par seconde
c'est incroyable tout le monde est
menacé
il est contre un premier jour des océans
et ça c'est génial
pourquoi c'est important que lutter
contre la pollution des eaux calmes
parce que je veux moi j'ai de quoi soit
on pourra peut aller à la mer soit on
continue ça va trop polluer la terre et
après on va mourir d'un second à 3
l'objectif est également sportif
l'apnéiste 46 ans doit réaliser au
minimum trois cent soixante cinq
longueurs en trois ans reprenant sa
respiration tous les 25 mètres pas
facile quand les déchets flottent à la
surface serait très compliqué parce
qu'il sert à rien at-il un âge j'ai
peut-être va même aller
parmi les sacs en plastique et ça
symbolise les méduses à laquelle les
tortues images les plastiques et pense
que ça mais je suis mort donc oui ça
ralentit la nage mais c'est pas grave
c'est moi qui a décidé que c'est comme
ça dû au jeu le jeu et j'assume andy
cabreira ville a finalement parcouru en
trois heures 395 longueur l'équivalent
de 9 875 km un record pour la bonne
cause qu'il pourrait de nouveau amélioré
dans les prochains mois c'est
l'événement le plus regardé sur la
planète la coupe du monde de football
débute demain jeudi en russie on
poursuit notre dossier de la rédaction
consacré au mondial à ce soir nous nous
intéressons aux supporters portugais
dans le département ils sont nombreux
après la victoire à l'euro 2016 en
france il espère voir les coéquipiers de
cristiano ronaldo réaliser un nouvel
exploit rencontre signé mickaël millero
la star de cette maison plaisir ouah
c'est lui cristiano ronaldo tom et
williams 8 et 11 ans deux frères
d'origine portugaise ont de grands fans
de l'attaquant lisboète et de son équipe
nationale
l'asi ses crampons clavé l'année
dernière place et quand ils tiraient des
coups francs et pierre faure alors quand
ils mènent des accélérations avec la
balle il a quoi une règle la scène les
actualités c'est ça au ballon d'or qu'il
a gagné cette année vous ressemblez au
portugal la passion ne s'arrête pas
qu'aux posters et olives les deux jeunes
passent également près d'une heure par
jour à regarder des vidéos des exploits
du portugal et de leur idole
et quand ils allument la console de jeu
le portugal est évidemment leur premier
choix inscrit son front
ronaldo parce que c'est une des grosses
rap et aiderez il fait ici une très très
vite
pendant la coupe du monde en russie les
deux frères ont fait leur choix ils
supporteront l'équipe nationale
portugaise une décision qui ravit leur
mère je suis contente parce que c'est
vrai que moi c'est mes origines et je
trouve ça bien que les enfants s'en
rappelle est en tout cas enfin le
supporte le portugal dans tout parce que
c'est dans le foot mais c'est aussi
c'est aussi pour plein d'autres choses
ils veulent tout le temps les lab en
vacances et adore hill valley vivre sur
les terrains de football yvelinois les
coéquipiers de cristiano ronaldo
également des supporters depuis sa
création en 1972 le club des portugais
de plaisir vibre au rythme des exploits
des lusitaniens et non de l'équipe de
france y en a certains qui sont pour les
deux moi je suis pour les deux j'habite
en france et voilà
notre famille portugaise on a dû son
portier on sera toujours toujours
derrière le portugal quoi c'est comme la
plupart des personnes qu'ils ont doublé
nationalité on a grandi ici
nos parents sont portugais ont fait nos
vacances au portugal donc voilà c'est le
portugal a déclenché le portugal abreu
tour pour vivre cette coupe du monde le
club a prévu d'organiser des repas
devant la télévision les soirs de
matches du portugal mais ils ne
devraient pas être les seuls à suivre
les rencontres dans le secteur très
grosse communauté surtout un plaisir les
clés et villepreux
il ya une grosse communauté portugaise
donc je pense que
les veilles de match où les sentais mal
fait et moi tout ça ou dans les cafés où
j'ai entre regarder les matches y aura
plus personne n'aura avec plus de 4000
habitants d'origine portugaise dans les
yvelines le département sera forcément
partagé entre le bleu et le vert et
rouge pendant cette coupe du monde
vous avez sans doute déjà croisé cette
famille de géants installés rue le nôtre
à montigny le bretonneux un intérieur à
l'extérieur à l'intérieur à l'extérieur
pardon a été réalisée par l'artiste
denis mondino à la fin des années 1990
une oeuvre en terre cuite dont la
rénovation arrive à son terme
elle avait débuté en juin 2010 est le
chantier est financé par saint quentin
en yvelines à plus de 58 milles euros
une restauration nécessaire car
l'installation s'était dégradée en 20
ans à propos collectées par patrick
jacques de dixmude je re j'ai refait les
partis qui étaient cassés qui était
détériorée il ya eu beaucoup de casse
sur la grande d'agir là bas le canapé le
livre le chien tout ça c'était à refaire
et puis presque la volière aussi
chercher tous les éléments critiques
avaient disparu de quoi faire frétiller
vos papilles pour cette femme journal le
salon de la pâtisserie s'ouvre ce jeudi
à paris avec deux exposants des yvelines
dont les moulins de versailles fabricant
de farine depuis 1905
reportage de camille lambert et tous qui
est nirhy lanto du blé local des
machines françaises c'est le credo des
moulins de versailles l'entreprise
fondée par la famille shaw des produits
des farines pour les particuliers et les
professionnels
une passion qui perdure depuis plus d'un
siècle il polit de chevet avère un
moulin à étampes dans l'essonne
son fils romain chaudet
ailleurs dans les salles et
main chaude et jean chaudet s'est
installée c'est à versailles en 1905
aujourd'hui sept personnes travaillent
ici les moulins de versailles ce sont
1500 tonnes de farine par an et 30
tonnes par jour
sur de la farine placer la farine
pourquoi passer cette farine la havane
stocker dans des silos
zilok et travers ce moulin
ces décisions qui sont réfugiés
avec un vent fort
au modèle des produits fabriqués à
partir d'un blé cultivé à moins de 100
km de versailles pour obtenir de bonnes
farine la sélection est rigoureuse
on a nos propres camions tir hrc blais
donc ça nous permet de le contrôler au
départ à l'arrivée
le blé a analysé jacques blais a une
signature et qu'il défende ses
caractéristiques
ensuite suivant
la farine ou qu'on va produire pendant
l'année pour la journée
vva
y'avait
un dosage précis de chaque cellule pour
pouvoir faire une star and est toujours
constante qualité homogène
depuis un an les moulins de versailles
se renouvelle la marque envisage de
lancer une gamme bio autre nouveauté des
préparations sucrées fondant au chocolat
madeleine autant de recettes à découvrir
au salon de la pâtisserie
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal très
bonne soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]